Blimey, this satnav's taking us
down some back roads, isn't it?
Yes, it's almost like I'm taking
you down a back road.
That sounds rude.
It does.
It's almost like
we're doing a rude trip.
We're driving from
Pratts Bottom to Balls Cross.
The question is why?
Because I thought it was funny.
'Cause it's funny, really.
Yeah.
'Cause we're children.
Along the way, we've both
picked out a couple of locations.
We haven't told the other
what those locations are.
We're gonna drive there.
You're gonna watch.
Or don't.
It doesn't matter.
Just stay here, watch it.
I don't know.
Do we care?
No.
Okay, to start, I'll drive first.
I've got somewhere
I wanna take you.
Alright.
Do I need to make the car noises?
Vroom, vroom, vroom.
I mean, the car's
gonna do that itself.
It's— It's a car.
It is a hybrid.
I didn't get a sports car
or anything for you, but...
Aw.
I might make them anyway.
I mean, feel free.
I did no research by the way.
(laughs heartily)
I have absolutely no idea
why it's called Pratts Bottom.
No, no!
We didn't talk to anyone there
to see if they find it funny.
We just...
We're just there
to amuse ourselves.
Yep.
We are children.
We're not even amusing you at this point.
It's just— just for us.
So we should explain
how this works.
I picked the start and end points.
I picked Pratts Bottom
and Balls Cross.
And then I sent the route to Matt,
and we've both picked
a couple of locations on the way.
And you'll see the ones
that are vaguely entertaining.
And we haven't told each other
where we're going.
So Matt's starting off,
'cause he's taking me somewhere.
Yep.
Later on, it'll be me.
I said we should tell you
how that works.
That was just a monologue
from me, really.
Yeah it was,
but I am also trying
to navigate a roundabout
and work out where we're going.
That's fair.
The thing that I want to note,
really, is that I fully understand
that the one thing that
the internet needs right now
that it hasn't gotten enough of is
Mhm. Yeah-yeah.
two white men making toilet jokes.
Yep.
So we're going to Balls Cross.
(wheezes)
The one piece of advice
I have for you
is don't cross your balls
at Balls Cross.
That's called testicular torsion,
and I wouldn't recommend it.
I've had it before, you know.
Have you?
I wouldn't recommend
it at all, no.
It's also a good name for a
death metal band, but you know.
"Hello, we're Testicular Torsion!"
(imitates electric guitar)
(death metal growl)
It's the sound you make
when you've got it.
Yeah.
'Cause it's actually quite painful.
I thought I'd take you somewhere
there was something you'd like to look at.
Alright.
I think this is gonna be
right up your street.
Hah, street.
'Cause we're doing a driving thing.
Yep.
Heyyy!
I'm quite glad it's you
doing this section, Matt.
You are much more confident
in the tight corners
than I would be.
I think I'd have scratched the car
back there going through
that tight bit.
That's growing up
in the countryside.
Mm-hmm.
And not my name on the waiver.
(both laughing)
Thanks, Tom!
Let's not hit the cyclist.
How many points to hit a cyclist?
Or the oncoming car.
I appreciate, Matt, that you had
a passing place there.
Did I?
Yeah.
But you went past the cyclists
and just bullied your way forward.
Wheee!
Speed limit.
(bewildered chuckle)
Thing is, we didn't move
any faster during that rev.
The car made zero velocity change.
You just...
It's the advantages of a rental.
Well, when it said it was hybrid,
I thought we'd get at least
some of the oomph from the electric,
the instant torque, but no.
It means it's just got a
big, heavy battery in the back.
Yep.
Just in case.
I'd put a Lamborghini on my rider.
You wouldn't fit in a Lamborghini!
I know, I've tried it actually!
I tried getting in a Huracán once...
and I could not get
through the door.
(loud phone ring)
Aaah!    Jesus!
That was the loudest ring!
So I think we're nearly there.
Alright.
I mean, this is somewhere
you don't know either, right?
No, I've never been here before.
I was looking on a map.
(laughs uproariously)
Welcome, Tom...
...to Titsey Viewpoint!
(both laughing)
Thank you to
The Titsey Foundation.
(giggling)
Do you like the sound of a
Titsey Viewpoint?
I do like the sound of a
Titsey Viewpoint.
(both devolving into giggles)
(dazed sigh)
So it says Titsey Viewpoint
is just up there.
Yeah. That's the plan.
Not that I've ever been here before.
"The Titsey Foundation...
...guided walks"?
I mean, we don't really have desire
Nah.
or time for that, I don't think.
There's a sign here.
"The Titsey Foundation Walk."
Ooh.
"You have a choice of
two different length walks:
either four miles or two miles."
No!
It is 32 degrees today.
That is not happening.
Lunch?
Lunch.
Welcome to Titsey!
(giggles) It's all right.
It's not like we needed to stay
for anything other than the name.
No, no. It's not worth
going to the viewpoint.
That's far too hot and
far too long in this weather.
So where we're going
for lunch...
Okay, which was also your call.
(chuckles)
I get to pick stuff later.
Yeah, we get to stay there
because it's lunch.
That's how lunch works.
Yeah.
You have lunch there.
Yeah, yeah, you do.
For those viewers who
don't know how lunch works,
you have lunch! (giggles, cackles)
(giggle fit trailing off)
(loud phone ring)
(startled laugh)    Jesus!
I have no way of answering
this phone call.
Tell— Oh my god.
Oh my god. That's so loud.
Oh my— So loud.
That's so loud!
That's so loud.
I appreciate though, the thought
of picking Titsey Viewpoint.
I just assumed that was
gonna be like a beautiful view
over the whole area.
Me too, but it was too...
...too much effort.
Just a...
...disappointing car park
with a very long walk.
(light chuckle)
Ooh, that's a good viaduct.
That's very nice.
You wanna get your phone out
and get a shot of it?
Yeah, I'll get a shot
of that viaduct.
That's a good viaduct, that is.
That's a very good viaduct.
A+ viaduct—
Well, no. It's maybe
a B+ viaduct.
I've seen better viaducts.
I like that it's iron.
(giggles)
Titsey sounds like the name
of someone from like a...
...noir detective film.
"Arr, it's Titsy. She told me."
(wheezes)
How do you like my
noir detective accent?
It's the same as
every other accent you do!
(cackles)
(giggles)
Go on, give us French!
Uhhn, Titsey!
Yes, it's...
"Je m'appelle Titsey."
Jackass Lane.
Heyyy!
Oh, we should have got
a picture there.
Well, we could help the
traffic jam with some jokes.
W—We could.
What's sticky and
makes a weird noise?
My brakes.
(groaning laugh)
(profuse laughter)
(giggles into wheezing)
Hey, we're driving Tom.
Yeah.
That means we should play
I Spy.
But as we know, I Spy is
quite a boring game.
So we can go for a slightly
different version of it.
The person who first
lays eyes on a pie wins.
First lays eyes on—
I— I Spy—
You're I Spying a pie.
Eyes Pie.
It might be a while
before we see a pie.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I'm not even sure if
where we go for lunch
will have a pie, but...
Will sell pies, okay.
(loud phone ring)
(startled yelp)
(hysterical laughter)
(indistinct)
Just...
So loud!
Just the right amount
of time passed...
...for us to forget!
A minute.
This is a lovely little village.
Yeah.
Headley Tearooms.
I thought I'd take you for lunch.
Hmm. That's very nice.
At the Cock Inn.
(belly laugh)
(giggle)
Okay. Yep.
Yep.
There's a pattern in the places
you've chosen, Matt.
I was like, choose some
interesting things to do.
(stammering)
Are you saying I'm a child?
I'm saying there's a pattern,
you know?
(chuckles)
Are we gonna have to eat sausage
or something particularly—
No! No, we're absolutely not.
I haven't even done
any driving yet.
Oh no, you haven't.
I was gonna say, "Which table
do you want?", but it's...
Should we go to the one
that the cameras are pointing at(?)
Yeah.
Okay.
So, Titsey Viewpoint...
...bit of a bust.
(wheezing cackle)
I didn't expect—
It's funny, 'cause
both words mean boobs!
I didn't expect that to land
quite as well as it did,
but I'll take it.
I don't think anyone wants
to watch us eat lunch.
So while we're doing that,
here's a sponsor.
Thanks for lunch!
I keep endorsing NordVPN
because they keep being
genuinely useful for me.
As you might have noticed,
I've been travelling a lot lately,
and it turns out some US sites
block visitors from Europe entirely,
because they can't be bothered to comply
with the privacy regulations here.
Now with a couple of clicks
on NordVPN's app
on my laptop or phone,
they're available again.
I'm sure you can think of
some other things
you'd like to access
from your country,
although do check their
terms of service first.
And plus, right now,
I'm in southern Switzerland.
So websites keep being all like,
"Non ti abbandonerò mai!"
Sometimes there's not even
an option to change that back.
But I turn on NordVPN,
and the problem's fixed.
I'm actually using them regularly!
Yeah, I'm kind of surprised too.
NordVPN works across Windows,
Mac, Linux, iOS, and Android.
You can have six devices
connected at a time,
and if it's not for you,
that's okay.
They have a 30-day
money back guarantee.
If you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscottplus
you'll find the best deal
they're currently offering,
whenever you're watching this.
Right, with all that said,
back to the show!
That was a good lunch.
Yeah. Happy with that.
And now it's my choice of location.
Yeah. Where are we go—
Can't ask where we're going next.
Nope.
'Cause that's the whole point
of the format.
That's the whole point of this.
I will say, it's not just a silly name.
We are actively...
Yes, you said that before lunch.
...actively going to
somewhere that is...
...content, I guess,
for lack of a better word.
It's something I don't think
either of us have done before.
But it's not a silly name.
Okay. Cool.
It's not even, not just a silly name.
It's not a silly name.
Not a silly name?
Not a silly name.
See, the thing is,
I— I know now...
that at some point
in the next few minutes,
the crew in the chase car
are gonna ring us.
Oh crap, yes!
(hysterical belly laugh)
At some point, this is gonna go,
"Brrring!" really loudly,
and we're both gonna startle.
And we're going to have forgotten.
Yep.
Because the best comic timing
we're getting all day...
Every single time,
is Chekov's phone.
Oh, there is no power
in this car, is there?
Yeah! See what I mean?
I really need to put my
foot down there,
and I got nothing.
And nothing happened.
Absolutely nothing happened.
It didn't even make a noise
that time.
Hey, Siri.
It's tagged to my voice.
(slightly deeper) Hey Siri.
That is a terrible impression
of me.
But I think it's actually tied to
the formants of your voice.
Ah, George Formant's Grill.
Yeah. Yeah.
Cock!
Yes!
Yep. Big cock at the roundabout.
There we go.
You know what I've had
going around my head.
Is it the Vengabus?
No, it isn't the Vengabus!
(hearty chuckle)
It's— Oh, I've forgotten
the name of it.
Hamilton.
Hamilton?
They don't sing the name,
his name enough in the song,
but it's been going around
my head a lot.
And we can't quote any of it,
'cause it's copyrighted.
Oh, it's copyrighted,
so we can't do it anyway.
Can I do the entirety of
"Alexander Hamilton" and "Guns and Ships"?
Yes, I can.
Am I able to do that on camera
for a YouTube thing?
No, absolutely not.
(loud phone ring)
Oh (bleep)!
Excuse my French.
Wow. Wow.
Every time. Every time.
I put my phone on—
(cackling)
That's what she said.
"Superbowl."
Does that mean they've got
the American football
world championships here?
No, no.
To reuse an old joke...
...it is just a load of superb owls.
That's what we're gonna—
Awwwh!
We're just gonna go and see
some superb owls.
I would love to see
Alright.
You know how you get
an owl sanctuary?
Yeah.
The phrase "lamb shank-tuary"
just popped into my head!
(laughs profusely)
No, it's—
We're going to an
owl shank-tuary.
They just fly up,
and then they just shiv you.
(continues giggling)
Welcome to a garden centre.
A garden centre?
A garden centre.
Oh, they're cheap here.
No, actually, we're coming just here.
'Cause you know
when you said "Superbowl."
Yes.
And I was like, "superb owl".
And you were like, "Oh, I'd like
to see some superb owls."
Are we?
Are we actually gonna see
some superb owls?
Hello guys. You're right.
Welcome.
Hello!
Thank you very much.
That's right, we've actually got
some owls for you to see.
Aww, amazing! Thank you.
So come through here.
I cannot believe...
we made that gag.
Yes! (laughs)
It was perfect.
So we have got Sorrel,
our Tawny owl here.
Hello!
And this is one of our British owls
Matt, you first.
that we have in the UK.
(distant screech)
So what I'm gonna do is
just tie him on here.
Okay.
So that way, if he tries to fly off,
it just takes you with him.
(group laughing)
Hello!
There you go, if you'll turn
your glove that way for me.
Just gonna put him on there.
What's his name?
His name's Sorrel.
Sorrel, hello!
Are you gonna look at me
in the face?
Hey, hello.
You've got big eyes.
Why are you cute?
I normally don't find animals cute.
But it's good
that I'm finding it cute.
(softly) Ohh, hello.
Hoo.
There we go. Good boy.
Hello, Sorrel.
I am holding an owl!
This is something I should have
ticked off my list a long time ago.
Because yeah, you can.
You can go meet an owl.
And the funny thing is,
as a millennial,
the first thing I think is
owl selfie,
but we don't need owl selfie,
because we have
two camera operators.
Oh, hello. Whoa-whoa-whoa!
Careful there, Sorrel.
Hold your arm still, he's just rebalancing.
That way, Sorrel. That way. Sorrel.
No, that way.
Sorrel!
Heyy!
(camera click)
There we go.
Aww, hello.
I'll take him back and
I'll get something else for you.
Oh, wow!
So this is Loki.
He's our Eurasian eagle-owl.
Loki?
He's just over— Yeah, Loki.
He's just over a year old.
(Loki screeches)
Wooh.
and being a Eurasian eagle-owl,
these are the largest of the owls.
Yep!
Okay. If you'll hold your arm
nice and steady.
Yep.
Little tip,
if you bend your elbow...
...you won't use all those muscles.
Bring it into your side, and you'll
relax those muscles up here.
(tenderly) Hello!
Wow.
(shriek)
Myeeh!
(others snickering)
I can't tell if you're having
an in-depth conversation...
or if he thinks
he's being mocked.
Oh, that is... unnerving.
Those eyes.
Yes, hello.
H—Hello.
He seems quieter,
but I think it's 'cause
he's pointing that way now
rather than at me.
Yeah. That is an owl staring
down the camera lens.
(Loki shrieks)
Last one,
something special for you.
Oh, you are beautiful!
Oh!
Oh, thanks. What about the bird?
Heyy!
I'll let you have a go first,
'cause you're the bird person.
This is a peregrine falcon.
Ohhh!
Wow.
I have only ever seen these
from a very, very long distance.
What's his name?
Hades.
Hades. Of course.
(wheezes)
Whoa, yeah.
Good boy.
(Hades chants)
Oh, hello.
I—
That's—
It's never occurred to me that
peregrine falcons have a call.
Tom, I think you need
a photo of this.
Okay.
I got a terrible photo of you
with the owl earlier.
I mean, I'm gonna get
the same photo here.
It's just...
Yeah, there we go.
That's... (chuckles)
Hi.
I dunno if the peregrine
can sense fear, but...
Can...
This feels like a stupid question,
but that's what I'm here for.
So dogs and cats can come
when you call their name.
Can birds?
I assume that they can't.
Well, to a point.
I'm not sure whether they
understand a name per se.
So what we do when we're
naming our birds,
we find something with two syllables
so they get used to the sounds.
Yes.
As opposed to a name itself.
I love how we've had a
little wholesome interlude.
Yes.
Because if we started it,
where did we start?
Pratts Bottom?
We started at Pratts Bottom, yeah.
We've gone to Titsey.
We've gone to the Cock Inn.
And then we've had a
wholesome bird interlude.
I feel like this says something
about our personalities,
but it's mostly just that
I wanted to meet an owl.
You like birds.
I wanted to meet an owl,
and I got to meet an owl,
another owl, and a falcon.
So I'm happy.
There is one destination left
to finish the road trip.
And I think that's Balls Cross.
It is.
Shall we go?
I'm not even gonna try.
No.
I'm gonna walk off, but
I don't like the sound of that.
I met an owl.
I'm happy with that.
Yeah, thank you for that.
That is something I would
never have chosen to do myself.
That's what I was hoping.
But, I enjoyed it.
Good.
And the first one was cute.
The other two were scary.
Quite scary.
Yep.
So our last stop is our destination.
Balls Cross.
Now the one thing
that a road trip needs...
Yep.
...is music.
But we don't have
a licence for any...
No, we don't.
But...
Uh-huh.
I have access to the same
stock music company that you use.
Oh yeah.
And I've put together a driving
playlist of stock music.
Amazing.
Do you have, like, epic road trip,
ending finale music.
I don't know, but I can find some.
(loud phone ring)
(both yelp)
At this point,
that's just dangerous!
The music can wait.
Hi.
Hello.
The music we need is like...
...soaring... anthemic...
hopeful.
This is the top result
for "epic finale".
Alright. That'll do.
That's montage music, that is.
♪ (soaring anthemic hopeful music)
Yeah, this is doing it.
I don't feel like we deserve it.
No, we're driving past
an unfinished Lidl.
And we're going to a place
called Balls Cross.
(giggles)
But you know what?
The sun's coming down.
Job done. I'll take it.
So through the hill
and roundabout we go!
Onto the A29!
Henceforth, we shall arrive...
...at the Cross of Balls.
(stammering)
Balls Cross.
I think that might be
over-egging it a bit.
I think you might be
over-egging your balls.
(giggles)
No one wants over-egged balls.
It's one of those things where
you tell someone you're doing this,
and they go, "How are you
gonna make a video of that?"
But we've somehow found
some content.
You're still watching.
Yeah.
Oh look, there's a sign!
Hey, it's got a sign!
It's got a sign!
Alright. Hazards on.
Yes!
Can we park here? We can park here.
Oh yeah. There's enough space here.
Ooh, there's a ditch.
Don't go any further.
Okay.
Yeah, that was good. That's good.
There we go.
We got it, right, hazards on.
It is nothing but—
Into park.
This shouldn't be funny.
There's nettles here.
This was a bad idea.
Good night, everybody!
We made it to Balls Cross!
Don't copy us.
We're not setting an example.
What should we do now?
Go home?
Yeah, alright.
You're driving.
Alright.
(yelp) There is a ditch!
(cackles)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]